lifelong leaders are lifelong learners
and if you want to win on youtube this
year
it's important to keep learning and
leveling up
whether it's with an audiobook or
actually grabbing a physical book
with a cup of coffee sitting on your
couch we are going to be revealing to
you
the five best books that every youtuber
needs to read this year my name is
heather torres and i am the host of the
think marketing podcast
and if you're new here welcome we
release a brand new episode
every single tuesday so make sure you're
subscribed wherever you're consuming
this content from
so you can be notified when a new
podcast drops on
tuesday now books are my
love language i love reading books and
it took
a while to get to five books that you
should be reading this year
if you want to start a youtube channel
now we're not going to be covering
necessarily business-minded or
entrepreneurship or leadership these are
for you
the youtube creator who wants to learn
and grow your youtube channel
this year these five books have been
life-changing to myself to sean cannell
and to the entire think media
team so you're going to want to lean in
you're going to want to listen up
because these five books could change
your life
let's get into today's featured
conversation
well sean i am excited to go through
these books um
i love all these books and as a youtube
creator myself these books have helped
me
grow a channel grow an influence and i'm
excited for people to
read them this year it was hard for you
to pick these five books to
be for youtube creators specifically so
we're not really talking about
leadership development or
business or entrepreneurship this is
truly for youtube creators and i think
it's important to
distinguish that because a youtube
creator is
kind of in both worlds right they need
to be creative but they also need to
apply certain principles
to what they're creating so let's go
ahead and get into book number one
hook point why did you choose this book
yes hook point by
brendan kane and this is a newer book
and this is an absolutely must
read for anybody that's creating content
and so
the average person right now is exposed
to between four thousand to ten thousand
marketing messages per day
the book reveals that over 60 billion
social media messages are sent between
people posted dms
a day so the punch line is there's more
noise than ever before
additionally algorithms are making it
harder for
people to see our content every social
media platform started
with if you got a bunch of facebook
likes and you posted most of those
people
would see it even youtube if you got a
bunch of youtube subscribers and you
posted
most of your subscribers would see it as
there's more noise on social media
if your video your content doesn't hook
the viewer get engagement
capture attention as the sub uh title
says
how to stand out in a three second world
that's so short
but in a three second world then the
algorithm will bury
your content so really that book is
about mastering the art of grabbing
attention in the first three seconds and
it breaks down a framework it goes very
in depth
you know i'll make some recommendations
with each of these books as well i think
i love audio books
i love ebooks i actually would recommend
at least ebook if not a physical book of
this one because there's a lot to
underline there's a lot to
strategize with there's a lot of tactics
so you kind of have it with you to
sharpen your content
but his basic framework is that a hook
point
has a powerful attention-grabbing
opening which we teach on
but let's clarify hook point's way
bigger than the opening 10 seconds of
your video
it's actually the big idea it's the
concept itself
will it stand out in that feed then your
hook uh your video also needs a good
story you might have an amazing opening
but then someone goes okay cool that was
impressive and then they leave after
that so you want to open up
conflict you want to lead to a climax
you want tension created different
things
the art of great storytelling even if
it's just a practical video leave
a reason for people wanting to watch and
then you also want authenticity that's
the third kind of big rocks around a
hook point
meaning click bait is really when you're
being inauthentic you think about what's
the craziest thing we could do
just to get attention but if it's not
aligned with your values who you are
then people will see that incongruency
so if you could find a synergy between
who you really are
as well as what will really get
attention and the book
really breaks that down so super highly
recommended
if you are a youtube content creator you
got to pick up a copy of hook point
yeah and the three second world that is
such i mean that's where we are now
right is that idea of only
really having to understand how to do
that quickly and i love how this book
you're right it is the big concept we
want to apply this to youtube that's why
these are for youtube creators
but this is for your overall messaging
that you're trying to do and
we're gonna leave all of these books in
the show notes below so you can have
kind of a recommendation of what that
looks like so we'll leave that in the
youtube description
and down below in the show notes number
two number two is written by one of your
good friends
pat flynn and that is super fans why did
you choose
super fans in no particular order by the
way this is just what i'm reading off of
our notes
yeah yeah yeah so super fans by pat
flynn
an absolutely incredible entrepreneur
content creator
and such a world-class person as far as
a father and life
and pat was one of our growth video live
speakers uh super fans is a
must-read book here's the subtitle the
easy way to stand out
grow your tribe and build a successful
business and
somewhat inspired from kevin kelly's
article years ago called 1000 true
fans in this case 1 000 true super fans
and that the secret to going full time
on youtube the secret to
building the business the life that you
want with youtube
is not necessarily a million subscribers
or even a hundred thousand but
potentially
one thousand super fans and the math
around that is no matter how the money
comes whether it's youtube ads affiliate
marketing
let's say you sell a 100 product if you
did and you had a
thousand super fans that actually
purchased that product that would be
100 000 a year and so you might have 10
000 subscribers but if you've got 1 000
super fans you potentially could build a
highly profitable business
and 100 000 is pretty remarkable like
again if you
only had a portion of that if you sold a
25 product to a thousand super fans
that's 25 000
in a year so that's the math but the
powerful thing about this book
is pat is just one of the most genuine
guys who loves his community
and he shares really practical things
you could do to engage your community
more to answer
uh their questions to dm people to kind
of surprise
and wow people to think about depth
and not just with i think that mistake a
lot of us make heather i'm guilty of it
too
is social media youtube we want with how
big can my subscriber number be
how can i get that silver play button
that gold play button
which is potentially a width number
because not all 100 000
of that those subscribers with the
silver play button are engaged
how much more powerful if you have depth
real community
real intimacy real relationships and i
think that should be encouraging because
the world right now especially kind of a
western culture sort of just promote
promotes like
size is all that matters growth is all
that matters the biggest number possible
is all the matters and that's not true i
think that actually
substance oversize as well and super
fans really gives
some very practical tactics every single
one of these books is amazing
but that is an absolute good investment
it's going to give you a ton of ideas to
help build a stronger community this
year
on youtube yeah and i read this one over
a weekend
so it's not it's full of a lot but it's
such a great read
also and just a great reminder to
remember that we're creating content for
other people we are selfishly creating
it because we want to grow a business
but the impact that your content can
have on someone and how to actually
foster online relationships i think pat
is really great
at doing the online and the offline
relationship building and that's such a
huge part
of growing a youtube channel we don't
grow our channels by ourselves we grow
our channels
with the support of people and so i love
that pat
really dove into the idea of how do you
connect on a deeper level with people
all right number three
uh is from one of the great authors i
think when it comes to marketing when it
comes to understanding community
uh which is such a big part of youtube
and being a youtube creator
you chose book the book called tribes
why did we choose
tribes yeah so tribes by seth godin a
famous book and if you haven't heard
about it definitely worth your time
i would recommend the last couple super
fans and tribes they might even be great
audiobooks you know to check out as well
because you you're getting concepts
you're kind of getting strategy
something you could listen to on a walk
and it's going to spark your mind give
you ideas
um here's the definition of a tribe it's
just a group of people with a shared
interest
and a way to communicate and i think the
unlock
of the book tribes for why this matters
on youtube
is a lot of people are trying to build
kind of a personal brand
they're trying to vlog and share just
their ideas about a bunch of random
things
and they struggle they're not growing
they're not getting the impact that they
want
and they're trying there's not
necessarily a cultural
or tribe anchor that they're connecting
to which could be the key to them
growing faster
let me explain um there was an event a
conference called
walker stalker con that was
built around just giving people from
the walking dead that loved the walking
dead a chance to come together talk
about the walking dead
booths people doing makeup they actually
got the actors to eventually come
so what do they have they had a shared
interest and they gave them a way to
connect and communicate
and a conference that was annual that
has grown over the years
so walker stalker kong became a
massively profitable business
around a shared interest that the people
who started
the conference did not create there was
already people into the walking dead
they just rallied around it when i think
about
um starting a youtube channel i think
about
i think seth james he's got a running
channel he didn't invent running
the lots of people in the world love
running obviously but
i watch him all the time because he
reviews running shoes he talks about how
to train more
so i already have a shared interest
running the way to communicate
youtube and yet he planted his flag in
an
actual proven community of people that's
what seth godin talks about as far as
the tribe
if you think about faith persuasions
christianity it's a shared interest
a way to communicate is a local church
but now you give people a way to connect
online
private facebook group that goes maybe
connected to your youtube channel
and now the shared interest maybe
if it's let's say christian fitness
you're layering interest
and it's a group of people who want to
get
healthier but also believe that you know
physical training is only of some value
let's also strengthen our spirit
they kind of have a similar mindset and
so the
it's a huge powerful book that kind of
unlocks the idea
that your goal as a youtube creator is
to stand up
and be a leader in a tribe that already
exists
as opposed to trying to create one from
scratch can you create one from scratch
if you think you can you may be able to
or you have a lot of audacity and good
luck with that
because again not a lot of people are
going to start a movement like
christianity or a viral show like the
walking dead
or an you know a massively popular video
game movement like cyberpunk 2077.
like it's it's hard to potentially
create a massive tribe
the power for most of us we could create
a full-time income
by beginning to communicate inside of a
pre-existing tribe
so i think the question people could ask
what is some of your hobbies what are
some of your passions
what are the things homeschool like your
channel is
a group of people that have a shared
interest but some of the ways that you
can accelerate a tribe is giving people
a way to communicate
now you're giving them the home school
house to connect with you but not just
you
each other we have our youtube influence
challenge coming up
it's people who have a shared passion
for online video a shared passion for
youtube that want to figure out how to
build
a full-time living around their youtube
influence or grow their business
with youtube shared interest is youtube
the way to communicate at such a deeper
level
is in the private facebook group that we
create for the youtube influence
challenge that's at another level of
depth
even beyond just watching like a think
media video or think marketing
podcast episode uh you know kind of in
more one-way communicate we're on their
ranch in questions
that is a good example of tribes and the
book is still definitely
there's a lot of value that we just kind
of pulled out of the book there it's
definitely still worth checking out
because seth godin gives you a bunch of
tools
for really being a better tribe leader
maybe identifying a tribe that you could
rise up and lead and contribute to
because chances are
think about how much opportunity there
is there's lots of different people in
the homeschool space it's a massive
community
there's lots of leaders lots of voices
and still room for many more
the difference between just creating
random youtube content and planning your
flag in a proven tribe could be the
difference between success and failure
for your youtube dreams
yeah and tribes was actually my
introduction to seth as an author
and i went down the rabbit hole he
really goes so deep but this was
it's such a good introduction to even
the idea of
joining that community so i love how you
said that this would be good for audio
because it is it really is one of those
that sparks
ideas for how you can contribute to an
existing tribe and put your own stamp on
the type of content that you're doing
a really great book to get started with
the next one
is primal branding now branding on
youtube
is so important i think it's really
pivotal it's what makes you stand out it
gives you the differentiating factor
it helps people to understand what
you're about and it helps to communicate
without
having to communicate so let's talk
about primal branding
yeah and i think we should maybe uh do
this in its own episode so i'll go rapid
fire through it so
patrick hanlon wrote primal branding
it's become a famous book in the youtube
community
because it specifically taps into why
influencers kind of viral youtube
channels
it's the seven primal codes that make
their youtube channel really stick and
really work and really make an impact
and here's what they are number one
story number two creed number three
icons number four rituals number five
language number six anti-believers and
number seven
a leader and the goal is that if you
have one or two of these you actually
could be doing pretty well
if you have all seven you could be doing
phenomenal these are actually something
that
we need to revisit or actually visit for
the first time with the think media team
i think you and i talked about these
2015 2016 and we probably haven't talked
about them since since our team has
grown
but even just re even if you've been
through the book
pull it off yourself read it again
because these primal codes are these
huge pillars that could be the key to
scaling your brand or really hitting a
tipping point so really quickly
story your brand needs to have a story
or a background the best brands have a
story
a lot of our story i mean it started
with me as a personal brand was
how i'm a college dropout small town kid
but also when my wife almost died
inspiring me to step up as a leader to
really figure out how to provide for my
family
to pay for medical bills to figure out
and it gave me
reasons come first results come second a
drive so a lot of times we share
our story then we even have stories
because the genesis of think media
in the heather taurus era and the
different eras so there's different
stories you share but your brand needs
to have a
story more than just why are you
creating content like what's the
background where what's the genesis of
this number two a creed
if this tells what you believe and how
you might be different or similar to
belief systems uh other belief systems
out there and so
this is even nuances like us saying we
want to help ten thousand purpose-driven
people create a full-time living making
a difference in the world with youtube
and online video
when we say purpose driven for us it's
coming from
family ethics values not just people who
want to make money on youtube but they
really want to make a big difference
just
a tweak that's maybe different than some
of the others out there and we're always
trying to refine that
the icons are the visuals we could
probably do better at this this is your
logos
your branding visuals you think about
the nike swoosh
you think about the tesla t you think
about some icons
that become the visuals associated with
a
movement or a branch supreme you think
about some of the really iconic logos
number four is the rituals and rituals i
think is like our last episode
it's not just our own rituals but it's
getting people to do rituals
like we need you creating that
significant video post a week and here's
a checklist for creating that video post
a week
we call it now the tuesday ritual the
think marketing podcast come on tuesday
ritual
make sure you listen to the uh think
marketing podcast every single tuesday
because we're coming at you
and so thinking about rituals some of
the most powerful movements
have rituals when you actually get this
is why
you take something like christianity
when it goes beyond
just being talked to at church on a
weekend but to when
you begin to pray and read your bible
and actually have
a vibrant relationship with god
throughout the week
that actually think about and
everybody's doing that everyone in the
movement
is a part of rituals language
common words you say or things that you
say we want to do an episode on think
marketing podcast of even helping
people with marketing language cpc cpm
that's like language and marketing but
even your insider language it could be
things like we say rise or grind at our
conference
you know over the years we've picked up
these phrases you say your race your
pace there's different things that
that may be originated with us but it
becomes kind of these language
things that happen in our culture
anti-believers people are afraid of this
one
who's your enemy it's okay to have
non-believers
like because when you really stand for
something there's gonna probably be
somebody who disagrees with you that's a
good thing
many are afraid to go there that's part
of the primal code and then a leader
who is the leader somebody steps up and
leads and if you think about any
especially youtube channel there's
typically a person
even if it is a movement and a community
of leaders that was sort of that
founding member and for most youtube
creators it's that one influencer
that one person and it talks it's
definitely a must read book
you got a lot of value out of that list
right there but uh
dialing in each of those and if you feel
overwhelmed i remember when i first
heard them
it was kind of like oh shoot first of
all it's like a spotlight on how much
clarity i don't have necessarily
in my brand in my business uh in my
youtube channel
but you just tweak these over the years
you start kind of saturating yourself
in the power of these brand elements and
remember you just have a couple of these
dialed
and it could change everything and you
could start having some success
you dial in all seven and your brand can
really hit the scale that maybe many of
us want virality
multiple subscribers 100 000 a million
subscribers
because you've really hit all seven of
the primal codes
so good and what i love so much about
these five books and we'll get to the
last one
is that these are ones that you can
revisit
over and over there are some books that
you read it and you're like that was
good but
these five books i truly believe these
like you said
we do need to go over these things again
with the think team and this would be
such a great opportunity for our
community to lean in
and say no i'm going to commit to doing
some learning i'm going to commit to
upping my branding and understanding my
fans and you know
really getting into more about how you
can grow your youtube channel
number five though sean i will have to
say was probably my most
favorite book on the list i'm not going
to give you too much props
but understanding these seven seas of
youtube success and really being the
number one
bestseller and becoming the best book
on youtube in the world it's a must read
for anyone who wants to become a youtube
creator i'm setting you up really to be
so humble on this next book
it's actually written by you and your
co-founder of video influencers benji
travis it is the book youtube
secrets why should they read youtube
secrets yeah i appreciate that
and uh yeah youtube secrets we are we've
been humbled and blessed that it
actually is the number one best-selling
youtube strategy book in the world
and even this year i think it's a must
pick up book
um you can grab the audio book for free
i think it's
tubesecretsaudio.com
of course you can also get the book on
amazon and what's amazing is the book
continues to i think we're over 50 000
copies sold
it still actually sells almost a
thousand or two thousand a month
and that's for good reason because we
work so dang hard on it we put
four years of our life into it over a
hundred interviews
distilling the principles down not just
into i think people wonder
well are the tactics current are the
tactics you know youtube's changing
well yeah but the seven seas of youtube
success is an unbreakable framework
like the seven seas of youtube success
are the elements that are gonna be true
on youtube in 2023
and 2026 and 2030 if youtube's still
around
10 years from now and i think it will be
and so youtube secrets i think yeah
as a refresher i know and i want to
thank a lot of people in our community
they've probably already read it they
probably already have it
it's probably a good time to listen to
it again i think all five of these books
read it listen to it again you know i
don't know if you do a book a week or
even a book a month if you want
this year to be remarkable then do a
book a month or do a book a week
journal make your game plan specifically
to get success on youtube these five
books
are really going to put some win in your
sales give you some pr fresh tactics
fresh reminders we never catch every
nuance out of a book so it will
bring even new ideas but then again
repetition
is the father of learning and the mother
of mastery
just like you said there's been times
where i will pick up a book i'm re-going
through the 21 irrefutable laws of
leadership and man every time i'm like
i feel like i've never read this before
i've read it multiple times
so repetition is so powerful it helps
you know bring clarity to our mind
fresh strategies to our game plan and we
want people to win on youtube this year
and i think that these five books are
absolutely a great investment to help
people achieve their goals
on youtube yeah and i just want to say
that you know um
for me it's learning through reading
has been something that has really
opened my eyes to the possibilities
and i think sometimes if you are jumping
into something new
like youtube and it does feel really
overwhelming
being able to take one of these books
just maybe one book a month or one book
every couple weeks
and really take the time to go through
it and digest what you're learning
i think it allows you to see the long
game of what you're creating right it
starts with the youtube channel it
starts with that first video
but it's going to eventually grow into
the brand that you're going to build
and i just want to encourage you that uh
think podcast listener that if
reading if getting a book and reading it
is something maybe
new to you i know there's a huge study
that says that most people don't
actually
read a book after high school and a
large percentage of people
never read a book after college and
that's so disheartening to me as a
homeschool mom
uh but i just i want to just encourage
you that whether you pick up all five of
these books or whether you just choose
one for this entire year
that it is your race your pace and that
even though you might look at a
bookshelf like shawn's and we're gonna
have other book lists because
you're a massive reader you you read
past me five times over with the books
that you're going through
but even if you just pick up one and
even if this is the first time you've
picked
up a book since high school i just want
to encourage you to lean
in to learning because as you are
connected with us here at think and as
you grow your youtube channel
that i think you're gonna see that we
are a group of learners and
we cannot get enough of the information
that are that's inside
of these books so i can't wait for
future episodes uh where you can
actually learn
more of our book lists and the things
that we recommend
but these five books think uh marketing
podcasts
this is your challenge for this year
grab this book grab some sticky notes or
a highlighter or a pen grab a good cup
of coffee
set some time aside and really start to
dive into the learning that can happen
from these books
and tag us like if you pick up a copy of
youtube secrets or these books end up on
your shelf
at miss heather taurus at sean cannell
on
instagram on your stories let us know
let us know which maybe and what books
are you reading tag us dm us send those
to us
because we love the knowledge share but
i'm you know it's kind of like
for book lovers they love taking books
on i'm that same person i
got them on my instagram stories i got
them in my instagram feed and so
uh share on social media if you pick any
of these up tag the author tag us
and we'd love to also see what you're
reading and what some of your favorite
books are
for specifically growing on youtube post
those in the comments and we can't wait
to hear from you
well those were the five books for you
to get started reading this year and
again we're gonna list them down in the
show notes below if you're listening
right now on apple or spotify
or they're in the youtube description if
you're watching this video on
youtube if you got value out of this
video make sure you hit that like button
on youtube and if you've not yet rated
or reviewed the podcast over on apple it
would mean the world to me if you would
go there after listening
and rate and review today's podcast this
lets apple know
that this is a great podcast and other
people just like you should be listening
to it so
make sure you go over rate and review
and take a screenshot
share it on social media tag myself miss
heather torres
and sean cannell at sean cannell rhymes
with channel
over on instagram so we can see your
favorite episode
so far and when you rate or review the
podcast and you leave your review
we get to read it on the podcast and
today's review comes from
rhys13 re says this is so helpful
a way better way to spend your time than
scrolling through social media
this also is critical to the well-being
of your youtube channel
along with think media's youtube channel
thanks reese for leaving that review
and i love being able to go through the
comments section of youtube
to be able to comment back to you and to
be able to read these reviews
on apple so make sure you're part of the
community and
join us in the reviews and let us know
what your favorite episode has been
maybe some testimonial meaning how
you've grown since you started listening
to us
or future topics that you would like us
to cover i would love to read
what you have to say in the comments or
on the reviews
and this episode is brought to you by
our youtube
influence challenge it's our seven day
free challenge
where you the youtube creator can join
thousands of other creators
online for free and learn our seven step
system our seven-step formula to growing
your youtube channel
getting views getting subscribers and
building a high impact and a high
profit youtube channel this year this
seven day challenge takes place
online so you have to register for it
you can go to
tubeinfluence.com right now to get
registered for that
seven day challenge and don't worry if
you can't show up every day of the
challenge
you have access to the recordings while
the challenge is still
going so make sure you register mark it
on your calendar and show up for the
seven day challenge
we also give away a few cool pieces of
gear
every single challenge you're going to
want to make sure to enter
to win some really cool gear this year
thank you so much for listening to
today's episode i want to thank you for
being a part of today's community
of this think community and for being on
the podcast today
go grab one of these books i recommend
that you
take the time to read one of these books
or all five of these books
this year let me know on social media
which one you picked up
and i'll catch you in the next episode
[Music]
bye
you